foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody TK Coleman what it
is the rest of our team is here in the
studio today as well coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about her basement
full of clutter and this new design
Trend called clutter core we also have
an outstanding lightning round segment a
live stream question and a listener tip
for you you can check out the full two
hour maximal edition of episode 376
where we answer four times the questions
and we dive deep into several simple
living segments that private podcast
episode is out right now at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say it with
me y'all
advertisements suck yes they do what's
start with our callers if you have a
question or comment for our podcast give
us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from regini my name is
Reggie I am from Columbus Ohio and I am
a patreon subscriber over 15 years ago I
had a paper crafts business I was a
one-woman operation with a toddler at
the time after two years of working
around the clock I burned out I had to
either find a full-time job quickly or
sell all the products I have left in my
basement which is around thirty thousand
dollars of stock I went back to work
full time and in the years that followed
I went through several life changes that
allowed me no time to declutter all the
stock in the basement plus I had Decades
of stuff that I had amassed in the house
fortunately I stumbled upon your first
film it was eye-opening for me so thank
you for that over the past year and a
half I have sold and given away a huge
amount of our possessions but I am still
struggling with the stock in the
basement I try to give away anything
that is not worth at least fifty dollars
however I'm confused about how to Value
uh this brand new but now Vintage Stock
collectively the stock is worth a decent
amount even with front cost factored in
but if it's sold as individual items I
have very little worth over fifty
dollars for example if I have a box of
50 packages of chipboard letters where
each package retails for six dollars
individually six dollars isn't much but
300 is substantial I have tried selling
some of these individual products as
part of a larger kit combined with other
products and I've also tried selling
them individually and involved on
Facebook Marketplace and eBay with mixed
success after nearly two years of this I
am tired I've given thousands of dollars
worth of stocks already given it away
but feel so guilty and stressed with the
stock that's bottomless and never ending
I am tired of the effort and time it
takes to list sell and ship I also find
myself getting annoyed that when I give
it away it's the same people every time
that come grab a Teddy I know any advice
on managing that emotion I have been
trying to focus on organizations and
schools but honestly I feel like I'm
still clinging I want to keep a small
stash for myself small being the
operative board but I'm struggling on
what to keep what to let go how to look
at and value the remaining stock and
just the feelings of clinging and guilt
that I'm trying to fight so I would
appreciate any advice you can provide
thank you so much
um Reginae I'm so sorry that you're
going through a difficult time of not
just physical clutter but there's a ton
of mental clutter that is being produced
by this the emotional clutter and I want
to answer your question head on but
first i'm reminded since we're doing the
whole episode today about clutter core
and I've got this article from
parents.com it's called clutter core is
the trend many parents need right now
and I want regini to avoid this trend in
her own basement because she's
inadvertently created this cluttered
space and that wouldn't be a problem by
itself I don't think but it's causing
all of this inner turmoil this suffering
this stress this discontent and of
course the fear as well and she's even
feeling Agony and anger toward other
people so the clutter in her basement is
leading her to lash out sometimes toward
other people or potentially lash out
toward other people Jordan on the screen
I'd love to put a picture here of
clutter core this is the new design and
Trend this picture that you're going to
see and Danny's going to give us the
iPad so we can take a look at it here
this
Trend this clutter core Trend this is a
picture from
architectural digest I'm going to hand
this over to
well I'm going to take a picture a look
at this picture TK and then we'll hand
it over to Ryan here this new trend is
called clutter core
so this is
this is in Vogue right now yes and let's
talk about why
we've decided
yeah yeah that is um
that stresses me out looking at it but
you know what for this woman right here
though maybe it doesn't stress her out
you know which is you know I'm not going
to judge her for it but yeah for me that
is that's
that's pretty extreme yeah I don't have
any judgments I have some observations
about this right so this picture that
you see on the screen right now is a
picture from architectural digest and
this new trend is called clutter core
where it's taking all of the things that
we're clinging to and now displaying it
and being proud of the clinging this is
not a design Trend this is a mental
illness that is disguised as a design
Trend it's holding on to everything not
being willing to let go I'm okay with
holding on to certain things in fact
later in this episode we're going to
talk about maximalism the intentional
use of beautiful objects totally fine
with that however with something like
this we're simply hiding the problem and
worse we're displaying the problem and
pretending it's virtuous I used to be
obese right this is obesity of stuff
it's the over consumption and then
looking at it and saying oh this is a
good thing I'm taking the thing that
stresses me out that makes me worried
that makes me depressed that makes me
upset and I'm going to display it to the
world and say look at me I can't let go
of everything and I'm proud of it no
this is creating illness in our lives
it's creating not just the discontent
but it's creating discontent for the
people around us as well and so the same
way as when I was obese and I kept
eating and consuming and consuming and
consuming I was also materially obese in
my own life Ryan and I when we were back
in the corporate days before we were the
minimalists we held on to a lot of stuff
and we accumulated even more stuff we
became possession obese and as we held
on to those things it was only a problem
because it got in the way and that's
what clutter is and so clutter core is
what it's getting in the way
it's celebrating the things that get in
the way I'm all for displaying beautiful
objects beautiful things owning things
that add value to your life I'm not for
re-labeling something that is stressful
and anxiety producing as something as
though it's positive and it is
useful in our lives these things if they
get in the way for you it doesn't matter
what you call it
it's a problem yeah yeah it just seems
like a
like a really
um I don't know like a hardcore uh
American Flex of like look at all the
stuff that I own here it is it's kind of
like how um
uh like back in the day uh different
like you know landowners they would grow
grass just to show that they had so much
money they didn't even have to plant a
crop they could just like you know grow
a lawn yeah that's where front yards
came from right yeah exactly and so this
to me seems like man it is the strangest
Flex I wonder if there's any value
though and maybe maybe you got some
insight on this TK but I wonder if
there's any value to someone embracing
their clutter so like a hoarder for
example they beat themselves up day
after day because they have so much
stuff but it's so overwhelming to like
even dig into you know that nothing ever
happens and it just continues to
accumulate is there any advantage to
just saying you know what I'm a hoarder
that's what I am and let me display it I
I think it's the same thing as that's
sort of giving up in a way right oh yeah
it's giving up now I also don't want you
to beat yourself up and that's actually
why I brought this question up for
regini because I don't believe that
she's doing the Clutter core thing but I
want her to avoid that if this clutter
which it clearly is causing some sort of
suffering in her life yeah and that
suffering is leading to discontent and
by saying what's she doing now so Ryan's
bringing up a good point I don't want
her to beat herself up over the things
yeah but I want her to understand that
it is also okay to let go yeah that's
right Ryan with respect to your question
is there any value I like to think that
with any
form a behavior that is self-defeating
or appears to be self-defeating people
are doing it because it gives them some
kind of value even if it's something
that they would be better off letting go
and the first step to letting go is
figuring out well how is this creating
value in my life and then how can I go
about replacing that value in a
healthier way in a way that has less
cost or less negative consequence one
thing that you see economically speaking
is something that's called costly
signaling costly signaling is a social
phenomenon whereby you take on a really
high expense for the sake of signaling
strength or reliability or endurance to
other people because the average person
can absorb that cost and if you can
absorb it it might say something about
you that creates a social result Banks
do this in terms of like their
properties they spend a lot of money on
these physical expensive properties
because they are signaling to people we
are here to stay and you can trust us
because you're probably not going to put
your money in a bank unless it
physically looks like it's going to be
there for a long time so having those
huge pillars and things like that
creates that impression people even do
it with sometimes things like the BMW
it's a social signal if you work in a
certain kind of industry you might want
to signal to your customers or to your
peers I belong here I'm not struggling
with money therefore you can trust me to
be your financial advisor it even
happens in poorer neighborhoods wearing
the 300 shoes might signal to people hey
I'm cool I'm somebody that is to be
respected or I'm somebody that's good at
basketball or I'm somebody that takes
care of myself doesn't mean that it's
the right decision it's not about
moralizing it but it's about
understanding it in terms of the
incentives and the benefits we get out
of playing these different types of
social games but bringing it back to you
Reggie
I think
Josh is absolutely right in terms of not
not overwhelming yourself in this way
one thing I would say to continue kind
of like this economic theme is that when
it comes to selling things there's a
difference between the catalog cost and
what other people are willing to pay and
sometimes it can be very difficult to
honestly face the reality of demand when
we are familiar with the sacrifices we
made to acquire something so if I paid a
thousand dollars for it and there's
nobody out there that's willing to pay
me more than 200 that's going to be
tough for me to sell at that price
especially when I have a magazine I can
look up or an industry catalog I can
look at that tells me the market value
is a thousand dollars that's the market
value
except it's not right because the moment
someone pays 200 front for it what's
going to happen is that catalog's going
to be updated and then the market value
is going to be lower that's what we see
happening in the stock market all the
time why why does that price go up why
does that price go down because it's
changing in relation to what other
people are paying when people start
paying more for it then the value goes
up when people are like nah I'm not
willing to pay a hundred dollars for
that stock it says 100 in the books but
that price is going to call you know
come down once somebody says okay I'm
willing to sell it for 75. so I would
think about the value of these things
not in terms of how much you already
paid for it but I would think about it
in terms of what is the real demand even
if that's significantly less than the
sacrifices I made at one point in the
past because even though you paid a lot
for it you're going to continue to pay
more for it in non-financial terms by
harboring the stress and the guilt and
the self-condemnation and the resentment
and the frustration of having something
that's taking up space in your life when
you don't want it and you got to keep
thinking about it and you got to keep
listing things and you got to keep
checking up with the listings and you
got to keep texting people and keep
responding to phone calls and keep
thinking about it that's a cost that
you're paying every single day and you
got to ask yourself how much is that
worth yeah we're really talking about
the additional costs here yeah so if I'm
in Regina's shoes the thing I want to
get really clear about she said I want
to hold on to some of these things okay
great what specifically do you want to
hold on well there's only one way to
determine that is by going through and
saying what will add value to my life
that's the first step and then also
understanding okay but is that still
going to get in the way just because
something adds value to my life doesn't
mean that I'm supposed to hold on to it
because there's the opportunity cost of
letting it go to make room for something
that is more special to me more value
adding more precious more enjoyable than
those things and so as soon as you've
identified the things that you want to
hold on to maybe of the thirty thousand
dollars worth of stock there's there's
five hundred dollars worth that you want
to hold on to then everything else is
something you want to get rid of right
how do I let go of material possessions
it's pretty simple it's a it's a basic
formula because it's a very mechanical
thing I list it if I can sell it for
more than twenty dollars now that
threshold is going to be different for
you and I probably need to update this
rule by the way Ryan I was thinking that
when we did the 2020 rule yeah that was
like 2011. yeah yeah so I looked it up
recently inflation it's now the 26
dollar rule oh okay all right 26 26 yeah
yeah within 26 miles 26 yeah anyway I
think you get the point for something
like this
it's probably not worth listing
something that is three dollars ten
dollars whatever because of the amount
of stress it's causing you however if it
wasn't causing you any stress I would
say say yes if you're enjoying the
process of selling each item
individually and you set up a booth at a
flea market and you're interacting with
people yeah that one's 50 cents this
one's five dollars great yeah then I
would say wonderful what a joyous
experience you actually get to have some
Joy from letting go of these things but
right now it's not causing Joy it's
causing anguish and it's causing fear
because you're afraid of letting go of
any of it and so let's say that you
could theoretically sell these thirty
thousand dollars worth of stock for five
thousand dollars right now and take a
twenty five thousand dollar loss that's
a sunk cost it doesn't matter but even
then let's say the stock is worth five
thousand dollars but you're gonna have
to spend a year getting rid of it
maybe it makes sense to Simply donate it
maybe losing the five thousand dollars
if you can afford it is the opportunity
for you to let go it's almost as though
you're paying five thousand dollars in
order to let go of not just the stuff
but all of the mental clutter and
emotional clutter that tags along with
it I I just had to do that I had two
bathroom rugs that I paid fifty dollars
for and this was a few years ago and I
was selling them on Marketplace for 20.
several people inquired so many no-shows
so many people rescheduling and this
happened over a period of two weeks to
the point where it's like I do not love
twenty dollars enough to work this hard
for it people are no showing me people
are wasting my time people are changing
their plans all sorts of things someone
who happens to work around the corner
shows up and says I'll buy the rugs for
10. now I paid 50 listed it for 20
couldn't be happier to give it away for
10 because what I lose in that ten
dollars from the listing and what I lose
in that forty dollars from the original
price I gain and never having to think
or talk about those rugs again
especially after spending two weeks
having more conversations about bathroom
rugs that I would ever hope to have
right so you got to think about those
additional costs yeah that's like you
said if you enjoy it do it yeah that's
how I look at it it's like
um Reginae um if you could afford
if you had thirty thousand dollars extra
in the bank and you could afford it and
you could lose that and it wouldn't like
make you go bankrupt would you spend
that thirty thousand dollars to get rid
of all your clutter and that's it's a
high price to pay but again the question
doesn't matter the price as much as what
what is it worth to you and it's
activity clutter as well because it's
taking up it's calendar clutter it's
taking up so much of your time trying to
let go of these things yeah that as
you've stated individually they're
essentially worthless right they're
they're not worth enough to try to sell
right and so I'm going to find a way I'm
going to give myself a deadline and the
mechanically I'm going to go through the
whole formula here so we'll wrap it up
by saying this there's an essay we'll
put a link to it in the show notes as
well this is It's called how to let go
and it's about letting go of possessions
and the first thing I'll do is I will
try to sell a thing if it is worth more
than a hundred dollars or fifty dollars
or twenty dollars you get to set your
threshold if it doesn't sell in a week
what do I do I don't just panic I lower
the price as TK just Illustrated right
if it doesn't sell within 30 days no
matter how much I want to sell it then I
will donate it if I can't donate it for
some reason because no place will take
it
I remember the I was just telling I
think Danny about this recently when our
last documentary came out less is now I
hit Netflix that I was just going to
Goodwill with my monthly donation box
and I walk up it's the one right down
the street from here I walk up with my
box and I'm like here I'd like to donate
things like I'm sorry we can't take any
more donations right now there's this
new documentary that just came out and
everyone is giving us their stuff so
good and I just sort of
scurried away with my box of stuff and
it was it was a big problem for me but
um usually most months I take it to
Goodwill but if they won't take it what
do I do if I can't donate it anywhere I
can't sell it then eventually yes I will
trash it but only as a last resort there
are plenty of things that you can do
with your stuff before simply renting a
dumpster and throwing all your stuff in
there we're not suggesting that but it
may come to a point where in order to
get it out of your life if you've tried
everything else
throwing in the trash might be the best
way to let go speaking of documentaries
our first film minimalism which you can
download right now at minimalism
film.com
uh we have six hours of bonus interviews
in there and a lot of people talked and
had answers about questions about
clutter and how we use our home space in
those bonus interviews I didn't make the
um then make the final cut of the film
but there were some really great
interviews in there so you can watch the
film over there minimalismfilm.com it's
on iTunes and Amazon and everywhere else
and also you can download the six hours
of bonus interviews at
minimalismfilm.com but Reggie we're
going to send you a copy of that as well
as the bonus interviews hopefully it'll
get you inspired to let go of this
excess that has taken up all that space
in your basement and in your heart Ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for the lightning round where
we answer your questions from Tick Tock
yes indeed you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock also Facebook
Instagram and Twitter at the minimalist
is our handle now during the lightning
round this is where Ryan TK and I do our
best within 60 seconds to answer your
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims and the
show notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like it looks like Chris has a question
for us which of your past objects in the
added value segments have since become
clutter
um Ryan you want 60 seconds yeah I will
uh yeah I'll go all right all right
Professor Sean go for it all right
here's my here's my pithy answer
um after taking an inventory of all the
things you've minimized you can minimize
that list too oh I love it so here's the
thing is you know we have this obsession
with holding lists not just with our
things but with people with our wins
with our losses I don't know why we're
so obsessed with lists but we are but
here's the thing holding a list doesn't
really do much for you there's probably
some somewhere out there we're you know
having a list of whatever inventory if
you've got a business or whatever it is
but the worst thing we can do is sit
here and hold a list on ourselves for
the things or the mistakes that we have
made so um yeah I have no idea uh you
know what what past objects um that were
in an added value segment that I uh let
go of or I had to donate because I don't
hold lists yeah you're not making an
inventory of the things that used to add
value to your life that you've let go of
yeah let's get 60 seconds on the clock
for TK Coleman Toccoa Le Prince Coleman
TLC what do you got for us
if it gets in the way it's clutter
what is the way
the way you want to feel
the way you want to think
the way you want to show up for the
people that you love
Duke Ellington said It Don't Mean a
Thing If It Ain't Got That Swing the way
is what gets you into your groove the
way is when you dance to The rhythms of
your true self the way is when you bang
to the beat of Your Own Drum and
anything that screws that up
no matter what anybody else thinks of it
it's clutter for you and life is
measured in terms of the moments that
you spend
in the way that you want to live and
anything that gets in the way
to even be focused on it to even be
preoccupied with it to even be obsessed
with it to even quantify your life in
terms of how many of those things you
got you've gotten rid of or want to get
rid of
it's all a distraction not only is the
stuff a form of clutter but so is a
preoccupation with this stuff so is a
you know determination to always count
the number of things that we have that
too is a form of clutter the way is just
being free and living your life without
counting without quantifying for TK we
have the 27 second shot clock
I'm sorry TK um that was 10 seconds over
um you'll have to do it again
uh one dollar Bob
take two yeah all right well usually
usually uh Josh goes first and he has
like an extra 20 seconds that he can
give me never oh yeah so because I'm so
pithy and when you chose Ryan at first I
knew I was screwed well I hadn't no I
had an extra 20 seconds too but Josh
took it
minimalism yeah I've got something pithy
for you but before we do I just want to
Echo both of of your points here and
I'll actually answer the question head
on as well because I think it will be
valuable to to Chris but give me 60
seconds and then we'll talk about this
here's my pithy thing question
everything because the things that add
value today
might become clutter tomorrow
and I think that's important we have an
added value segment on the podcast
because we highlight things that add
value to our lives it could be my belt
it could be a song it could be a book it
could be a poem here is something that
is adding value to my life
but if it stops adding value I'm going
to stop holding on to it I hold all of
these things Loosely because if I don't
hold on to them Loosely what happens I
cling to it and the more I cling I start
clinging to this I cling to that I cling
to this other thing it really weighs me
down when I feel so weighed down the
only thing to do is not to cling more
tightly it's to Simply let go
that's my pithy thing for you just in
time I will say one thing that I've
recommended in the past as an added
value
item was and I just was reminded by the
by Professor Sean about this I have
something called a so right do you do
you ever have one of those no so my
psoas gets really tight my psoas muscle
gets tight oh it's like and it digs into
the okay yeah and so I used to use it
all the time but then I found some I
found a gospel therapy and I started
doing a gosscu therapy and the thing
that added value to my life that's so
right which I've talked about on this
podcast at some point before it stopped
adding value I stopped using it and so
when I stopped using it I let it go so
someone else could get value from it
because if I cling to it what happens I
stop getting value from it and I also
limit I prohibit everyone else from
being able to get value from it as well
hey brother stop advertising
we're actually I've got a uh someone who
works in the advertising industry wrote
in to us to say they're unsubscribing
from our podcast because we say
advertisements suck I'm actually going
to do that I'm going to talk about that
during the sucky ad segment on the
private podcast let's check in with our
patreon live stream in a moment but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists you all
probably know we have this nice little
side project it's called minimalism.com
it's called minimalism life is is the
name of the side project back in 2016
the minimalist teamed up with
minimalissimo Carl over there and
Alberto over at five style to bring you
the best of minimalist design travel and
intentional living minimalist well-being
and we have a team of minimalist writers
as well who write over there at
minimalism.com and we're looking for
some new writers so if you're an
aspiring writer or you're a writer who's
written great our side project is
looking for New Riders to share your
minimalism stories you can get involved
and contribute to our weekly Journal
over at minimalism.com once you go over
there you just click the get involved
Tab and you'll find all the details and
who knows if you write something that is
really that really resonates with the
Audience by the way it's hundreds of
thousands of people who read over there
the minimalism life blog and the weekly
Journal that comes out if people find
Value in it you could also participate
in the minimalism Life podcast which has
become my new favorite little micro
podcast it's like three to five minutes
the first five or six episodes are out
now I think the first four episodes are
out right now and you can find those as
well at minimalism.com you know how many
requests we get for uh guest essays I
mean I get emails all the time uh if you
email our the email we have on our
website it's hey I'm so and so would
love to have a guest or I'd love to to
be a a guest on your blog can I write an
essay for you this is a great
opportunity for people who are trying to
do that that's exactly it yeah
minimalism.com in Alabama let's check in
with the live stream what do you got for
us we have a question here from Angel
she says I heard you mention
occasionally that you do someone else's
podcast any chance that you have a
directory for podcasts that you've done
yes we do uh the minimalist.com
media you can find we've done over 700
media interviews over the last 12 years
now wow yeah the reason being is one
year we did 400 in 2014. we did 400
interviews and that's why we're on the
road we did those 119 events and we did
a long book tour with our second book
everything that remains and so we've
done 700 interviews and you can find all
of them over at the minimalists.com
media let's do one more question Alabama
here's a question from Andrea she says I
struggle with wanting to remodel my
space we can't afford what I want to do
so I keep filling the void with new
furniture to refresh my space any
thoughts on accepting an imperfect space
Oh yes so every space will always be
imperfect right
you are already perfect you're born
perfect no one looks at a baby and says
oh my God we need to perfect this baby
maybe we need to improve this baby
here's a self-help book for your baby
I'm just thinking that to me I'm just
thinking about how I wish my mom would
have got me ear reduction surgery when I
was a baby but anyway
and yet we are constantly obsessed with
improving our space why because we feel
incomplete inside us and one of the
reasons we feel so incomplete is because
marketers advertisers major corporations
do a great job of making us feel
inadequate and when the way they do that
is by saying hey you have a problem you
didn't know you have a problem but we
have a solution for you right and so
selling Solutions is actually part of
the problem that's why I try to have
Solutions on this podcast I have
observations and and some insights
recipes that may or may not work for you
it depends on where you are in your life
I will say this during the the private
podcast later we do every week we do a
minimalist home tour and we're talking
about clutter core this week and we're
going to dive deep into the Clutter core
movement and this design Trend but then
I'm also going to show you a part of my
home that is filled with beautiful
objects but not just my home I want to
show you Axel vavorte's home who's my
favorite interior designer spoiler he's
a maximalist my favorite interior
designer is a Maximus and really enjoys
beautiful objects to him however it's
the opposite of clutter core here's one
thing that I do and I'll I'll answer
Andrea's question with this the one
thing that I do regularly with the
objects in my house I move them around
constantly so it's the same stuff yeah
but in different areas we learned this
from Bob we have Bobby on from queer eye
he was on the podcast we did a whole
episode about interior design and I
learned this from him it's like I have
things that I think are beautiful and
useful and they add aesthetic value to
my home but the way that I keep it fresh
is I'm going to move this vase to this
part of the house I'm going to move this
from the living room to the Shelf in the
hallway yeah and by doing that I keep
the same things but the space is
constantly refreshed every month I'm
moving the things around the one thing
that this isn't a judgment Andrea it's
just an observation
about you can't afford
to remodel the place that you the room
that you want to remodel so you buy new
furniture to to put in this new room so
again this isn't a judgment but it's
almost like when I you know I see
someone who is trying to like really get
a hold of their finances they buy all of
these uh Finance books yes and you can't
spend your way out of out of uh out of
financial debt just the same as you
can't spend your way out of not being
able to afford to remodel that room so
again this isn't a judgment but yeah you
might have to just kind of rearrange
some things right now every time you
want to buy a new piece of furniture put
that in the the remodeling fund yeah you
know I used to have bad luck with
computers and it's the strangest thing
every time I would go to an airport
um something would happen one time my
computer is on the the security belt and
the guy stops me because he wants to
check me out and I can see my computer
like at the edge somebody else's luggage
just pushing it over and it's gonna fall
and I'm like my computer might be
Peter's like sir sir stand out stand
right here sir and I watched my computer
fall and just like
and I'm like are you kidding me there
was another time where some guy just
like puts the wrong computer in his back
and it's mine and like I'm working with
the airport to try to catch this guy
this would happen to me at least once a
year one of my friends said to me he
goes you know I don't know why but this
is clearly part of your vibration or
your destiny or something like you're
just that guy he's like what if you
leaned into it what if you just made up
your mind that every year you're just
going to get a new computer and that's
going to be your thing stop resisting it
and I was like you know what okay I'm
gonna stop resisting it once a year I'm
just gonna get a new computer whether
something happens or not right nothing
ever happened to my computers after that
it's just a mental trick right so
sometimes the solution is to lean in so
you can ask yourself why can't I just be
happy with the way things are well why
can't I just be happy with liking to
switch things up every once in a while
you know there's room to perhaps double
down and say hey I do this anyway is
there a way for me to make peace with it
can I just say hey every six months or
every year I'm gonna rearrange things
and move things around because I'm not
the type type of person who's cool would
it always being the same I like to mix
it up so maybe there's room to make
peace with what your behavior is showing
you about what you truly enjoy man TSA
pre-check is way way less expensive than
buying a new computer every year
you just leave your computer in the bag
and send it through look at that yeah I
needed you uh four or five years ago
I think the thing to remember here for
Andrea is
peace cannot be acquired happiness
cannot be acquired Tranquility cannot be
acquired yes you can buy new furniture
for your home you can buy new clothes
for your body you can buy a new car to
take you to work you can buy a new home
you can get a new apartment outfitted
with all new things you can buy
beautiful objects that add some sort of
aesthetic value to your living space but
you'll never be able to purchase
happiness and that's what we're trying
to do quite often we're gonna buy this
thing it's going to give me a sense of
purpose or meaning or Joy nope those
things will only cover up the peace the
joy
the eudaemonia that is already there
within you Alabama will check back in
with the live stream on the private
podcast but in the meantime what else
you got for us here's a minimalist
Insight from one of our listeners
hi my name is Natalie I'm from Cochrane
Ontario I would like to share how I
limit my shopping on Amazon
I only pay with gift cards When shopping
online so once I have added the items to
my cart I then have to buy a gift card
at the store and apply it to my account
before finalizing my purchases this
makes buying online less convenient and
it allows me to think before I buy if it
is not worth my time going to a store
and buying a gift card then I probably
don't need the items in my cart
that is our minimal episode for today
we'll see you on patreon for the full
two hour maximal edition of episode 376
which includes a million more questions
from our listeners a long discussion on
all of the perils and pitfalls and the
disagreements we have about clutter core
we're also going to talk about
maximalism a bit on that episode uh
we've got a minimalist home tour in
which we review some of the Clutter
so-called clutter in my own home
we've got our Infamous obsolete object
segments we got much much more of less
including an outstanding added value
segment for you if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast at patreon.com the minimalist or
click the link in the description to
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our weekly maximal episodes play
and your favorite podcast app you'll
also gain access to all of our podcast
archives all the way back to episode
zero zero one yes indeed all right y'all
if you leave here today with just one
message let it be this
love people
and use things
because clutter core will never work
we'll see you next time y'all
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign